wallows at PAX East I got the awesome
opportunity to try out the virtusphere
which is basically a giant hamster ball
that allows you to walk freely in the
game environment if you recall at PAX
Prime I did a video on the virtuix Omni
treadmill which is basically the same
principle although executed in a
different manner the virtuous sphere
acts as much as you'd expect with you
stepping inside and walking around to
have the entire device orbit around them
there is an oculus rift in the center as
well as a handrail that moves around on
wheels to make sure that you don't
disorient yourself now there was no way
to record the actual game that I was
playing but this demonstration isn't
about the game itself and more about the
device the virtusphere is daunting and
there are many concepts that you have to
get used to that aren't translated in a
real world number one there is momentum
so if you start walking in the direction
the sphere wants to keep going that way
that's why when you see hamsters on a
hamster wheel they can sometimes lose
control but that's just an exaggeration
to show a point the virtusphere works -
its concept if you walk in a direction
and will go that direction in the game
and that is what we are trying to
accomplish with virtual reality so since
I couldn't stop babbling like an idiot
inside the sphere I have to now describe
the experience while I'm outside the
sphere however it's impossible to put
into words what it was like to walk
while inside that hamster ball number
one it was walking inside a game number
two that was not an accurate
representation of how humans walk the
versus sphere is a big heavy ball and
when a big heavy ball is spinning it's
hard to turn and make minor adjustments
yes they constantly told me to make baby
steps but that is not natural motion
that being said it was an absolutely
amazing experience it blew my mind that
I was actually walking inside the game
combine the oculus rift which is already
a virtual reality device with another
device that allows him to truly capture
the motion of being in
game and you get something that is a
unique and interesting experience that I
would try again if I ever got the
opportunity and while we may not see
these in living rooms anytime soon I
could definitely see this in an arcade
or as a premium experience in some
exhibit I would do this again a million
times over now I know you guys probably
want me to compare this to be Omni but
at the basic level they are totally
different devices they have different
mechanics they have different principles
and they approach virtual reality the
same way I can't say one is better than
the other although I will say that the
Omni is more likely to be in your living
room in the near future however compared
to the golden standard of virtual
reality as we all understand it today
they are not quite there they are fun
and I would recommend giving them a try
but they are not perfect so thank you
all so much for watching and I thank the
developers for giving me a chance to try
their devices thank you everybody
bye-bye